right ahead
authorities in Arizona opened fire on a
suspect after he allegedly pulls out a
gun and points it out of police dog's
head he's out he's out
take him here take him here
it happened on August 25th in Tucson
Arizona officials there say the Tucson
Police Department SWAT was performing
surveillance on 49 year old Francisco
Galarza police say this was in relation
to felony arrest warrants for home
invasion and bank robbery investigators
tailed gallarza to a Circle K gas
station and approached him when he
exited the store he's out he's out
take him here take him here
officers Chase Galarza through the
parking lot eventually releasing a
police canine named Cairo to help take
the suspect into custody
the police say gallarza allegedly
removed a black handgun from his bag and
pointed it directly at the dog's head
that's when multiple officers opened
fire after that officers tried to
provide gallarza with medical attention
but he was later pronounced dead on the
scene the officer-involved shooting is
now under investigation by the Pima
County Sheriff's Department a separate
law enforcement agency for the latest
developments in this story and all
things True Crime stay with long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie